I saw you at we were at your uncut
Gemma's premiere you're in a suit here
tonight how's that I'm Sayla feeling a
suit I think this is the one suit I
think I've warned us about six events
already so far my wife keeps telling me
to get out of them nothing seems to fit
right so this is it I changed the tie on
occasion well because you know you're so
fit now so that's a good thing if it
doesn't perfect body I gotta tell you my
heart was pretty warm just now you and
your wife just looked so happy together
like how happy does that woman make you
well she makes when we're doing good
it's the best that we're always happy
when my wife's having a good time and
she deals with a lot of me me stuff I
just got to run around with me a lot we
have a good time doing it and it's this
is all amazing and then when we get home
that's when the kids and stuff that
feels more normal when it feels right
but it getting to go to New York City
for a couple days and have a nice time
together that's guaranteed goodness you
mean it doesn't feel normal for you to
be in a suit on a red carpet taking
pictures that's not really
well Congrats on tonight I mean so much
praise for the movie I gotta ask you
we're all thinking you're gonna get an
Oscar nom how would that feel for you it
would be 20 years old and I don't I
don't care I mean it's not why you you
make a movie and this movie in
particular I knew was something
different and I was excited to do it but
yeah I don't I don't want it to be that
if that doesn't happen I gotta be like
oh I'm psyched I got to be in this movie
that's and that would be good too
that's tough sorry any reunions you're
looking forward to tonight Kathy Bates
was just your water boy well I didn't
know Kathy would say I'm gonna go track
her down and don't tell her I play
foosball she doesn't know that and you
and Brad Pitt can we get a picture you
guys
you have to work on paying yourself
[Music]